Bethlehem Christmas 2019 and an unusual
procession along the town's star Street
for the Christian population here this
is special a moment for Pompey in the
Christmas story it was this route which
Mary Joseph and a donkey took past Inns
which were full to a stable where Jesus
was born in a manger and this they
believe is a fragment of that manger
returned on order of the Pope after
centuries in Italy to Bethlehem no
question that this is a very important
symbolic moment for Christians in this
town but it belies that much much wider
and ongoing struggle
this is the story of today's Bethlehem
it is a place of deep frustration a
population that feels forgotten and
strangled and that word you hear over
and over right across the land they call
Palestine occupation it's eighteen years
since Israel began to build its
separation barrier a wall and a fence
the length of the West Bank which splits
Israeli Jews from Palestinian Muslims
and Christians for Israel it's a wall
which is as necessary now as it ever was
justified they say because it stops
terrorists it keeps their people safe
for Palestinians though it is a barrier
to peace and I saw of course but much
more than that
and this is this is your house here yes
this is my house surrounded from three
sides what they tell you here is that
it's part of a land grab and a system of
apartheid imagine to live with the gray
dark gray surrounded you flare Anastas
was born in Bethlehem this is the family
home the view once was of her uncle's
house and olive groves beyond now it's
concrete so this here is what it looked
like on the day that the wall went up
what was this 2002 2003 2003 before
Christmas time it's so hard
economically it's in a big prison
our life is limited no freedom and we
don't we feel that there's no justice
for any Palestinian and we don't know to
whom we are belong to
Claire remembers vividly the battles
here the Israeli crackdown against the
Palestinian uprising the Second Intifada
as they called it that was some time ago
today in 2019 that there isn't fighting
like we used to see does that mean that
things are better or not it's another
kind of fighting we call it like hidden
fighting more than like like direct
fight to kill us it's killing our soul
it for me it's more hurt than other
things
when you live struggling with injuring
your heart slowly that's another kind of
death it's more terrible actually
of course it's up to both sides just
yards from Claire's house but on the
other side a different story from the
man who built the barrier and there was
shooting from dirt down toward the
traffic that runs on the main highway of
Israel meet Danny Tessa
a colonel now retired in the Israeli
army in 2002 on the orders of his
government he mapped the land and chose
the route for the barrier you talk to
anyone on the other side of that wall
and they'll tell you that this what
we're looking at here is one of the
biggest barriers to peace in this region
well before the fence was built there
was terror here before that we're
talking 20 years ago that I'm talking 20
years ago that doesn't matter the matter
is living or or not and that the main
issue the main issue is that we want to
have good life with the Palestinians the
problem is the Palestinian terror at the
moment the Palestinian terror will stop
and we'll have some arrangement to live
together there is there is no need for
death
it is true that since it was built
attacks by Palestinians on Israelis have
dropped to a fraction of what they once
were and yet coupled with the building
of the wall something else has been
happening
from every angle from the north side to
the west to the south and from the east
we are being surrounded by the
settlements back on the other side we're
driving with Sahil Kalia I'm really at
this point very doubtful that it would
go away soon it's clear that every
aspect of life here on the Palestinian
side is dominated by the wall and what
it stands for at the right you can see
that all stores used to have live in it
and it were they were all closed off but
it's the impact of Israeli settlements
that he wants to share us on the if you
look at the left side this is part of a
fraud settlement which is called the
Seven Hill settlement because stand or
extend across Seven Hills so this is an
Israeli housing some housing settled
inside the West Bank side the West Bank
all illegal and illegal not just that's
not just what you're saying illegal
illegal under international law and this
is illegal the settlements are
contradictory to international law UN
resolutions around 600,000 Jews live in
about a hundred and forty settlements
like this built across the West Bank in
their own gated communities on the
Palestinian side of the wall
Israelis are populating what they
believe to be their land and with
incentives from their government and now
backing from Donald Trump's United
States
the Land of Israel but the problem is
it'll say you'll and it's also our land
still you have no right to deport people
to force people of their land only to
fulfill a biblical fear theory you don't
violate you know human rights in the
name of God so where does all this leave
things will the level of entrenchment
that we found on both sides is hard to
exaggerate to get back to the
negotiating table will require bold
leaders both in Israel and in Palestine
leaders who are prepared to compromise
and right now they don't exist in Israel
politics is a mess with the third
election in 11 months this coming March
and in Palestine they haven't held any
elections since 2006 the disconnect here
between the people and their politicians
is huge it is clear that the status quo
is not sustainable but the key to a
peaceful and prosperous future here well
that is still out of reach
mark stone Sky News in the Holy Land